the reality of decorating is that it may
seem simple but it's so easy to get
overwhelmed by choice for me the first
step in decorating any room is creating
a brand like kind of a road map a north
star to refer back to in a world of
endless choices you kind of need a
guidebook to remind you of your goal and
strategy and that is where branding
comes in
i'll try and make sense of it
[Music]
glamour equals swagger
good design can be transformative
i got this
[Music]
so
how do you start
the key to coming up with a brand is to
do an honest inventory of who you are
but always always with an eye towards
who you want to be
creating your brand is an opportunity
for self-improvement not
in an abstract way but like in a
tangible way to help you move your goals
forward your brand can help make you
your best self
a brand is a way to create an identity
in the past branding was the way that
companies identified and advertised
their products so you recognize them as
different from the rest and by their
version of soda dishwashing detergent or
clothing so that's branding from the
past but now branding has become a far
wider reaching concept that applies not
just to business but to everyone
the idea of having a personal brand
helps other people know who you are and
what you stand for and you can do this
in design too a personal brand gives you
the opportunity to steer your design in
the right direction about 25 years ago
simon told me about this new book i
think it was called brand you
and he's like oh everyone's talking
about how you have to have like your own
brand and i was like wait a brand isn't
that like
cereal that you get on the shelf or a
soda or whatever like i've never heard
of it and he said no no no it's this new
thing where you like have to come up
with your own personal brand and at the
time it seemed absurd and quite arrogant
cut to today when
everything is a brand i'm a brand
eurobrand he's a ranch she's a brand
we're all brands i want to help you
figure out what your brand is
to create your brand start by inventing
a three word branding guide the first
word should be an adjective that
describes like a personal trait like are
you sporty are you preppy are you
luxurious flamboyant fresh
the second word in your brand should
create kind of an environmental vibe so
are you coastal palm beach like
farmhouse scandinavian traditional
hollywood glam southwestern
french country mediterranean and the
third word or phrase should be an
occupation or lifestyle you can choose
this occupational identity from the
reality of your life or
better yet
who you want to be so socialite
gallerist fashionista yoga mom
sailor
when you put these three words together
you can create a personal brand that
will be a guide as you make any and all
decorating decisions here are a few
brands i've made already so you might be
a
fun-loving east coast sailor
a well-read scandinavian barista
or how about a fun-loving desert
homesteader
or an elegant new orleans dancer
yeah i mean they're all like they're
kind of wild but like i say them and you
get it and that's what a brand should be
you should hear the words and be like oh
i get that
branding is a serious business like for
reals so you cannot stray too far
however
you should also feel free to get a
little creative with some of the words
you choose i'm a big fan of the
portmanteau word the combination of two
words i think the word that most
accurately describes me
is hangry because i'm always hungry i'm
always a little bit angry and hangry is
a perfect portmanteau word so if you're
feeling constrained by the word branding
eat it
feel free to try to create your own
portmanteau word for one of the words
a modern hippie could be a mippy
mine are usually very
obscene
let's talk about my brand and my journey
from being a potter to being the
amazing
home lifestyle entrepreneur magician you
see before you today
um when i started my career as a potter
which happened quite by accident i was
unemployed and i was making pots and my
parents were like we're not giving you
any more money so you either sell a pot
or you get a job and i was 27 and broke
and i sold a pot and i was selling my
pottery to barney's and i was just so in
the moment i was making these kind of
cool groovy striped pots that were very
clean and modern and minimal and for a
few years i just was like in it and i
just kept making pots i was working like
24 hours a day seven days a week
making pots and when i finally
had a chance to kind of breathe and come
up for air
i started to think about
what i was saying with my pops like i
was making these cool stripy pots and
there was the visual vocabulary of what
i was saying but i also thought to
myself the pots that i'm making also
have meaning like i'm communicating
something conceptual and i and i thought
to myself what am i saying with my
pottery and i thought well
my pottery is modern it's really about
creating new innovative modern design
with a nod to the notion of modernism so
it's definitely modern and i also
thought you know my work is very much
rooted in
america like i am inspired by and part
of the tradition of american design
which i think is reflective of what i
think of america as being which is a
country of optimism and possibility so i
i think and i hope that in my work i was
making pottery that was modern
that was american in its spirit of
optimism and possibility i thought
my pottery is glamorous i thought wow
that's kind of what my pottery is it's
modern american glamour
and that was a revelatory moment for me
because once i kind of realized what i
was saying with my work that i was
creating pottery that communicated the
idea of modern american glamour it kind
of gave me permission to apply that very
same ethos to
myriad
categories and so it was a real like
light bulb moment for me i thought well
you know if i'm making these pots that
are about modern american glamour like i
could do the same thing with pillows
so i thought yeah i can do pillows as
long as they
refer back to that idea of what i'm
trying to communicate with my work and
you know that that was something i
realized 25 years ago and i think that
even now as i've become an older and
more haggard potter i'm still saying
exactly the same thing with my work
whether it be
pillows pots furniture lighting interior
design they all come back to that same
core principle
the brand of my work modern american
glamour and by creating a brand just
with my pottery something as mundane as
pottery that very ethos that i created
is able to translate to all of the
products and things that i surround
myself with today it all refers back to
the big bang of my brand my revelation
that i was communicating
modern american glamour
so having my three word brand as a
guidepost has really led me through my
entire design career i always refer back
to it so i really mean it when you are
thinking about designing your own home
it really helps to try to figure out
exactly what you want to communicate and
it is a process of contemplation and
taking true inventory and might even
seem silly but it's so worth it in the
end because if you have your three word
brand as a guidepost and you always can
refer back to it you can
you can figure out whether you're
straying from your vision or not and you
probably are going to want to stick true
to your original vision so come up with
your three word brand it's worth it
the truth is when i started out as a
potter it never in a million years
crossed my mind that i was creating a
brand that i was creating a company that
i was doing anything other than just
being in the moment and making pots so
the fact that my
world my work
and my life has evolved to
encompass this business
is complete
shock and surprise it's a very very
happy accident um there's been a lot of
misha goss along the way but
in the end i think it's been worth it
there's been a lot of mishagos but it's
been worth it
so you can find inspiration from
branding really from any creative field
and a design muse like an actual
interior designer muse of mine who had
an incredible sense of branding is mario
botta
so he's the antithesis of what you
actually do but you're saying he's
inspiring to you just because of his
commitment to his
vision mario barter had such a sense of
clarity and his three-word brand was so
simple maribwata was the prince of
chintz and that's exactly who he was now
chintz is like a glazed cotton fabric
that feels sort of very social like
upper east side and is typically printed
with flowers so it's sort of a very like
girly ladylike flower very 80s yeah it's
like a very girly lady like flowery kind
of very adzy laura ashleyish
look and mario bata took the idea of
chint and just
went with it
yes um that's surprising to me that you
name him because he's the antithesis of
you but i guess that's why he's he got
your attention i think a great brand is
something you just know it when you see
it and you know yeah mario botta really
was very very different from me but i
have such respect for what he
accomplished and his complete clarity of
vision and his
full-on commitment to floral chants and
america room was like chintz on chins on
chintz on chins on chimps on chins
on chins with a poodle on top
in the world of fashion one of my
favorite brands is tom brown
i think tom brown the
iconic menswear designer has such a
clear
simple and rigorous point of view and
approach design
and always had and always has had that
since he began how would you define tom
brown's design style and brand well he's
associated with gray he's associated
with white stripes it's very rigorous
almost like a military
uniform his menswear in his couture
women's wear he plays a lot with a
broader canvas the reason that you find
tom brown to be a noteworthy brand is
because he's had such conviction about
this palette this limited palette and
this rigorous approach to design yeah
and i think that you can take
inspiration from tom brown because he
doesn't get distracted like he's
somebody who
conceived of his brand and though i'm
sure he's confronted with a billion
influences and inspirations i'm sure
he's tempted to stray a million times
but he is co-mitted and um i really
respect his ability to tune out the
noise and execute exactly what he wants
to execute and i think there's a lot to
learn from that idea when you think
about how to design your own home
i think the key to a good brand or good
branding exercise is to think about
people who
when
you imagine them you know exactly what
you're gonna get and i think an
unexpected example of that is the
filmmaker m night shyamalan who first
kind of came to our attention with the
sixth sense and an m night shyamalan
movie you know exactly what you're going
to get it's going to be kind of scary
it's going to be a little like
intellectual and there's going to be
some freaky surprise and his consistency
of vision has made him a totally
recognizable identifiable and probably
most importantly bankable brand and um
yeah what do you think about that
i'm thinking of other directors who have
that i guess frederico fellini
you know what you're going to get la
dolce vita blah blah blah the fast and
the furious you know what you're gonna
get you're basically talking about
committing commitment yeah and i think i
think that fast and furious is a perfect
idea of a franchise that is just like
doing slight ever so slight evolutions
of an idea and i think that's what a
really good brand is it establishes
itself and then just sticks to its guns
i think the key to a good branding
expert is the idea of simplicity and
communication so that the second
somebody sees
what you're selling whether it's a movie
art fashion architecture they know what
they're looking at they understand what
you're trying to communicate and i think
the king
of branding is milton glazer who has
come up with some iconic
slogans and logos that are
that are so simple and pared down and
like you see them you know them and he's
kind of the gold standard milton glazer
like when i think of milton glaser i
think of i love new york i heart and
wide like it's incredible it's genius
and it's sort of funnily enough i
actually think it's just a riff on
robert indiana's iconic love like he
took the idea of that and just kind of
twisted it you know what it is you know
when you see it well milton glazer
worked at a time when brands were
coca-cola
um
you know kellogg's yeah kellogg's
campbell soup so he works on that period
where those were brands now of course we
use the term branding in a much broader
sense but i think he's still
inspirational to anybody who's working
on their brand yeah i think i think you
can
take lessons from all of these iconic
brandsters
to help create your own personal brand
in your
self in your fashion and for our
purposes your home
so once you create your three-word brand
you need to use it to guide every part
of your design your whole design should
refer back to your three-word brand so
when designing my shelter island home my
three words were eccentric
coastal and rich hippie or rippy and i
think you can see
my eccentric coastal rippy vibe in each
and every move i made in that house
so let's break it down eccentric
i would say that a 12-foot tall macrame
owl is eccentric coastal
is
really determined by location i think
that's a very important thing is to to
give your design a sense of place
i am very lucky to have a house that's
right on the sea and i wanted it to feel
coastal and everything that entails to
me coastal is
casual it's a feeling of indoor outdoor
and it's about the sea and i think my
house feels coastal and i guess the last
word rippy rich hippy uh is kind of
about um
the fact that a lot of the the materials
in my house are very like natural a
little bit global it's about
you know custom tiles and
wood ceilings it's about sort of an
honest but luxurious sense of material
so i think everywhere you look you kind
of see that you're in an eccentric
coastal rippy space another example of a
brand that i did for for my bestie when
i designed her house in florida
i
could very easily sum up exactly who she
is she is flamboyant aka bold glamorous
and confident
palm beach which is both a place and a
state of mind and happens to perfectly
capture my client and friend and
fashionista
because she is a fashionista and
fashionista is another one of those
words that really
is it's a a job and a state of mind um
and her house is exactly it is
flamboyant bold colorful it couldn't be
palm beachier and you know the second
you walk into that house that you are in
the house of a fashion maven
flamboyant palm beach fashionista voila
so those those examples of branding are
really based in reality you know my my
health needed to be a reflection of me
my friend's house needed to be a
reflection of her but if you want to
make the varsity move
and i encourage you to do just that um
you can create a character so instead of
making the house exactly who you are you
can really
create a fantasy and i'll give you an
example of of a time i did that um when
i designed the uh when i designed the
parker palm springs hotel um i invented
a fictional muse who i called mrs parker
and
mrs parker
uh
she didn't exist irl but mrs parker in
my mind was a free-spirited
glamorous socialite and
the hotel that we created i imagined was
mrs parker's estate and every square
inch of that hotel is definitely the
space of a free-spirited glamorous
socialite i knew that she was a world
traveler so we filled the hotel with all
the things she bought in her
free-spirited travels around the world i
think her free-spirited self can be seen
in the fact that there's a real global
feel it feels like the home of a jet
setter who just sort of traveled the
world and collected things willy-nilly
and brought them home because she loved
them and she knew they would work it's a
varsity move to create a character as
your fictional
occupant of your house but why not why
be constrained by who you are why not be
who you fantasize about being don't you
want to be a free-spirited glamorous
socialite i know i do
when doing the parker hotel um which
took years we spent so
many hours in meetings saying like well
what would mrs parker do would mrs
parker have that would mrs parker have
this and when it came time to actually
design the
the
restaurant the hotel i was so sick
so sick of hearing about this
inspirational fabulous mrs parker that i
imagine well
i wonder who mr parker is um and we
decided to make the restaurant which is
called mr parker's a reflection of mr
parker's brand and mr parker in my mind
was a loose clubby degenerate um and i
think those words are probably all kind
of the same which is fine because that's
just who mr parker is and the resulting
space which is really
hedonistic and decadent you can only
imagine the debauchery that would go on
shane mr parker and um yeah mr parker's
it's fantastic go check it out when
you're in palm springs
mrs parker the muse for the entire
parker palm springs hotel um really has
a distinct character
and i felt totally free to break from
character in this one space in the hotel
mr parker's because mr parker is his own
man
and
it's it's really a cool juxtaposition
between these two spaces so i guess the
takeaway for you is that
not your entire house has to conform to
the exact same brand like you can kind
of tweak and evolve the brand room by
room if you want to um but there should
be some relationship between the
different rooms and brands in your house
the social life part is quite evident
mrs parker is
a popular and um
rich and luxurious lady but i think the
most important word and it's a very
important word to discuss is glamorous
and glamour is a very very strange word
it's word that's thrown about constantly
and i think it's really really hard to
define but i have my own definition of
glamour to me glamour is about
confidence it's about not caring what
other people think if i had to come up
with a synonym for glamour i would say
the word is swagger
glamour equals swagger and we should all
aspire to swagger the varsity move is to
create a character
but i think you're i think you're more
than just a varsity player i think you
could be a super varsity player and i
think the super varsity move is to take
a fictitious character and put them in a
location so i my forever muse is jackie
o i mean she was the epitome of glamour
and sometimes in my mind's eye i think
well what if jackie o was in big sur how
do i combine the sort of the rustic
natural beauty of big sur with the
international glamorous socialite status
of jackie o and i find that by combining
those two disparate spirits a sense of
dynamism and creativity can erupt so
go super varsity take a fictitious
character plop her into a fabulous
location and
watch explosive creativity unfurl when
i'm not daydreaming about sending jackie
o to different glamorous locales and the
um the glamour that wouldn't sue i'm
also often thinking of andy warhol my
other forever muse the
king of pop style and cultural wisdom
and
kind of just the king of everything like
i don't know if i can get through a
minute of any day without thinking about
andy warhol and so sometimes i think
like all right why don't i send andy
warhol to london what would he do how
would he essentialize the english spirit
and reflect it back in the same way he
did the spirit of america when i think
about andy warhol i think about how he
took mundane objects and celebrated them
and made them iconic and monumental
think about the soupkin
and when i think about london in at
least in my mind's eye i think about
historicism i think about the johnson
museum which you guys really need to
check out because that john stone knew
how to arrange an object believe me
and i think it would be really exciting
and interesting to see how andy warhol
would take
a mundane english object um and put it
on a pedestal so yeah andy warhol london
kind of
gets my gears going
my overarching philosophy about design
is that
design at its best whether i'm making an
object or creating a room should look
completely effortless
it should look as if it was just always
there as if
it was uncovered rather than created i
think that a good object just you're
like oh right that thing that looks so
familiar but
you have no idea how it happened you
just know that it exists and it needs to
exist um and i think that
in order to get there
requires a lot of effort unfortunately
like to get a good design to design a
good room you just have to think and
think and think and work and work and
work
but at the end of the day if you do the
work to define your brand really really
clearly and use that as a guidepost to
all of your work
it takes away so much of the guesswork
and really leads you to creating a space
that looks exactly like it's supposed to
be in terms of effort when designing
your room you shouldn't feel bad if you
screw up and need to keep like thinking
and reworking on it because i think any
creative process really takes a lot of
work you know that famous expression
writing is rewriting it's really about
starting and then stepping back looking
at it analytically being rigorous and
just keeping on going and going and
going so in a funny way as writing is
really rewriting designing is really
redesigning just keep at it don't be
intimidated and just charge forward
your three word branding guide will give
you a north star so you don't stray too
far from your design vision keep those
three words in mind as you're
conceptualizing
shopping and evaluating your design you
can't stray too far from your brand a
dalliance is okay an affair not so much
you need to marry reality with fantasy
combine who you are
with who you want to be
you